في التطورات الميدانيه ايضا نستعرض معكم
مواقع ابرز الجبهات اذ تشكل مدينه باخموت
احد اهم محاور القتال بين الطرفين هذا
ووصفت مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيه الوضع على
الضفه الشرقيه لنهر بخمت بالحرج رغم قولي
قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه كما ذكرنا انها
صدت اكثر من محاوله روسيه للتقدم حيث تدور
اعنف المعارك شمال المدينه اما في اقليم
دومباس فقالت مصادر مواليه لروسيا في
دونيسك ان القوات الروسيه حققت تقدما في
محور افديفكا المتاخمي
وهاجمت مواقع للجيش الاوكراني في بلدتي
كريس نوغوروفكا ونوفو ضخمه بينما قالت
الاركان الاوكرانيه انها صدت المحاولات
الروسيه على اكثر من محور وفي خرسون حيث
اعلنت سلطاته وخيرسون المواليه لروسيا ان
الجيش الاوكراني واصل قصف مناطق مدنيه على
الضفه اليسرى
لنهر كما قصف مدينتي و فويا كخوفكا وياشكا
وبلدات المجاوره لهما ما ادى الى تضرر
وحدات من منشات البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
في تطورات الجبهات كذلك قال المتحدث باسم
المخابرات الاوكرانيه
ان اوكرانيا ستكون مستعده لهجوم مضاد في
الربيع بهدف تحرير كل الاراضي الاوكرانيه
بما فيها شبه جزيره القرم واشار الى ان
التوقيت المحدد للهجوم المضاد يعتمد على
عوامل عده من ضمنها توريد الاسلحه الغربيه
واوضح المتحدث عن احد الاهداف
الاستراتيجيه سيكون محاوله ما سماه دق
اسفين في الجبهه الروسيه بالجنوب بين شبه
جزيره القرم والبر الرئيسي لروسيا وقال
المتحدث باسم المخابرات الاوكرانيه ان
الهجوم لن يتوقف قبل اعاده اوكرانيا الى
حدود عام
1991 ولم يستبعد سيبسكي ان تضرب اوكرانيا
مستودعات الاسلحه في الاراضي الروسيه لا
سيما في منطقه بيل غورود وقال ان الهجمات
على اوكرانيا ستبدا من هناك وان هذا يشكل
تهديدا على سبيل المثال لخرياف